yeah you know chess players are just so
smart and just so fit and just just such
just Machines of optimization yeah I
think a lot of chess players are also
just like really good looking as well
[Music]
yeah you have intelligence
you know looks
um athlete Athletics you know what else
humor of course as well so what else can
you ask for a bachelor I know what are
chess players
players now that's really the hard
questions
um
that's honestly the best
a lot of chess players are lacking money
yeah but I think in general they have a
lot of great traits then doesn't really
matter if you're smart good looking if
you can't take out your girl on a date
oh but in 2021 well I can't think the
girl thing oh true yeah
yeah like if I would have did for me
it's only equal yeah